- [Narrator] As humans,
we have a lot of senses
that we put to use on a regular basis.
They include sight, smell,
taste, touch, and hearing.
But have you ever
wondered how it all works?
How do you look at a beautiful
painting in an art museum,
or smell the rain outside on a stormy day,
or feel that your favorite pair of socks
are still a little damp,
and need another cycle in the dryer?
How does that information make its way
from our sensory organs to our brains?
Well, the answer lies
in the nervous system.
If you remember, our bodies are made up
of multiple complex organ
systems that work together
to perform all different
kinds of functions.
Today, let's talk specifically
about the nervous system,
which is an organ system that allows us
to sense and respond to our environment.
To begin, the nervous system
contains specialized cells
and cell parts, called sensory receptors,
which are able to pick up
signals from the environment.
These signals are called stimuli,
or stimulus if you're
talking about just one.
Stimuli can come in many different forms.
For instance, mechanical
stimuli are physical in nature,
and are involved with our
senses of touch and hearing.
You can strum a guitar,
feeling the strings
against your fingertips,
and listening to the
unique tones it produces
as the strings vibrate.
Those are all mechanical stimuli.
Chemical stimuli are made up of molecules,
and are involved with our
senses of smell and taste.
To illustrate an example,
imagine eating a tasty bowl
of chicken noodle soup.
As you spoon mouthfuls
of soup into your mouth,
your taste and olfactory receptors
are flooded with molecules
that signal the qualities
of the food you're eating.
These molecular signals
are chemical stimuli.
And in this case,
the molecules from the chicken noodle soup
convey that the food
you're eating is savory,
and extremely delicious.
Lastly, electromagnetic stimuli
are involved with our sense of sight,
and include the light that
comes into our eyes every day.
The sunlight that makes you squint,
the traffic lights you see on the street,
and the vibrant and diverse
colors all around you.
These are just a few examples
of electromagnetic stimuli
in the form of light.
So then what happens after
sensory receptors detect stimuli?
Well, once a sensory receptor
receives the information,
it passes this information
along nerve cells.
Here's a picture of a nerve cell,
which is specialized
to transmit information
in the form of electrical signals.
These signals are transmitted
along nerves to the brain,
which is then responsible for processing,
or organizing sensory information
from different sensory receptors.
After processing the information,
the brain can elicit a response,
and also store the information
in the form of a memory
for future use.
For example, imagine you're playing catch
with friends in a park.
Your sensory receptors pick up information
as you watch the ball come towards you,
and feel the wind on your skin.
Signals from these receptors
travel along nerve cells to your brain,
where all these different
signals are organized.
Then your brain elicits a response,
such as moving to just the right spot,
and putting your hands
out to catch the ball.
And the brain also stores a memory,
perhaps remembering playing catch
as a fun activity that
you'd wanna do again.
You can almost think of
this flow of information
from a stimulus to sensing, to processing,
and finally, to eliciting a
response or storing information,
like a complex relay race.
Sensory receptors pick up
message in the form of stimuli,
and pass this information along
to nerves, and to the brain.
Only in this relay, the end
result at the finish line
is a response to the stimulus
and information storage.
So to summarize,
today, we talked about
how our bodies sense,
and respond to the environment.
Information is transferred from a stimulus
to a sensory receptor, to nerve cells,
and finally to the brain,
where processing occurs.
Whether we're aware of it or not,
our nervous system is working
at rapid-fire speed every day
to provide us with the information
our bodies need to sense
what's in our environment,
and thrive in it.